over the last year and a half to two
years we've seen a real resurgence of
pseudo-intellectual thinking especially
led by this internet movement that I
think people who watch this show are
sort of familiar with and there was an
article in The New York Times recently
by Barry Weiss that has gotten a lot of
attention writing about what some are
calling the intellectual dark web and I
didn't agree with nearly everything that
she wrote in the piece but she does do
an interesting job of exposing people to
the fact that this movement exists
I guess maybe movement is the word I
don't even know if we can really call it
a movement and explaining to people sort
of some of the players involved in some
of the ideology involved and I don't
even really know exactly who's part of
this movement the article in The Times
talked about sam harris jordan peterson
eric weinstein dave rubin ben shapiro a
lot of different people were mentioned
and most of the people described in the
article are certainly not intellectuals
by any stretch of the imagination but I
think that the more interesting part is
less about the intellectuals or
pseudo-intellectuals themselves and more
about why they are increasingly why
there is a group that is increasingly
attracted to those types of characters
and as I've said before and we've talked
about pseudo intellectual ism a lot on
the program to really fight back against
pseudo intellectual ism you have to
understand the two sides of the problem
and in the New York Times article and
elsewhere some of the people I mentioned
will ascribe to their followers a desire
for truth and truly open debate about
all ideas with no taboo topics as the
reason for their success right their
story is people are so starved for real
discussion about real issues because of
the repression of the liberal media and
political correctness and sometimes they
blame post-modernism that there was just
this overwhelming pent-up demand for
exactly what these intellectual dark
Weber's or whatever you want to call
them or offer
now I completely disagree and it's a
two-part issue as to how it all happened
the first part is why do we have a
population that's particularly receptive
right now to pseudo-intellectual ideas
that can sometimes sound unique and
correct and accurate and then part two
is the sort of inability to distinguish
between real intellectual thought real
critical thinking real seeing of
knowledge or seeking knowledge for the
sake of knowledge versus just pseudo
intellectual nonsense that sounds pretty
good
without really saying anything unique or
even in many cases substantive so let's
start with part one the environment I've
spoken about that quite a bit there are
people right now who feel disassociate
they feel as though whatever real or
perceived status they have may be on the
brink of going away and they have been
primed to accept faux intellectual
nonsense that seems to explain why it is
that they're experiencing what they're
experiencing and maybe even present some
ideas as to how they might be able to
stop it or fix the problem they see
they've been conditioned that academia
is just liberal indoctrination and bad
or that actual intellectualism is bad
that they won't get the real truth
because of censorship and political
correctness and all of that stuff and
that view exists more on the right but
not exclusively there are left-wing
elements to this as well for sure there
are people on the Left who have also
fallen for movements like men's rights
activism that they won't get the truth
about the oppression of men because evil
feminists won't allow the truth to come
out or sjw's or whoever then there's the
question of aside from being primed for
pseudo-intellectual answers to why the
world is the way it is why do they fall
for the faux intellectual nonsense
specifically from some of the people
were now seeing and a lot of it is
presentation style right it's how people
speak it's marketing period they they
hear the seemingly esoteric language but
they understand it because the truth is
what these people are selling and it's
not actually difficult to understand for
them the truth is it's not unique or
noddle
either but it's very appealing the
desire for the feeling of authority that
knowing the real truth brings to them is
this is a big tractor beam to borrow a
phrase from Star Wars and they heard
from someone who's managed to get around
censorship that these are the people
that are going to tell you the real
truth with no political correctness
getting in the way and a lack of context
is often what makes the phone
intellectual nonsense effective right
people hear ideas that sound good enough
and they're different than what they've
been told before so they buy it without
considering the real implications of
those ideas in the real world and in the
end there's a lot about simply people
that command authority as a factor here
right sometimes it's people that speak
quickly like ben shapiro or loudly or
eloquently like jordan Peterson or
whatever right there's a that's a huge
factor the optics of the presentation
and that's actually a really similar
mechanism as to what's at play within
the world of pseudoscience which we'll
be dealing with in a minute mini-series
soon but there's also some overlap with
the conspiracy theories I've explained
before that with conspiracy conspiracy
theories the appeal is sometimes simple
and neat explanations which even if
untrue are more comforting than the
truth which is often some version of the
world is a gray area of unpredictability
period right so look I'll give you an
example to illustrate the point from the
conspiracy world rather than we were
attacked by people on 9/11 and we either
couldn't or didn't stop it and people
randomly died it was a it was a tragedy
with a huge random element to it it's
more comforting to some to believe that
9/11 was controlled and planned maybe
even by people in our government maybe
george w bush combined with a world
trade center that was painted with
thermite the walls were painted with
thermite paint for years to make the
building catch on fire more easily and
the analogy with pseudo-intellectual ISM
is for example take the race and IQ
discussion which has become very popular
rather than recognizing and evaluating
the multi-generational socio
economic issues that on a test like IQ
lead to what appear to be correlations
of race and IQ so on and so forth
instead how about some races are just
smarter period inherently right or
another example from the so-called
intellectual dark web there are real
differences between men and women that's
a popular one yeah does does anybody
deny that that's not original that's
what really gets to me about the so
called intellectual dark web I've heard
nothing unique from any of them and I
mean you know looking at their full
range of topics
Jordan Peterson's book twelve rules for
life assume that the person you are
listening to might know something you
don't
Wow wait a second you go back and you
read how to win friends and influence
people by Dale Carnegie from 1936 and
his book is filled with the exact same
idea be a good listener encourage others
to talk about themselves let the other
person do a great deal of the talking
try to honestly see things from the
other person's point of view there's
nothing even remotely notable about
jordan Peterson's twelve rules of life
or for life or whatever another example
is the idea around free speech and
censorship that right there are a lot of
people activated by this intellectual
dark web movement because they feel like
they can't say what they want to anymore
there's nothing remarkable about that I
grew up around people like that the sort
of hill town folks from around the
Northampton Massachusetts area they
believe that the political correctness
of the college towns in in the Pioneer
Valley were suffocating them and
preventing them from saying what they
wanted to say although it was never
really clear what it was they wanted to
say that they actually couldn't say
that's not unique it's not new it's not
even notable in any way or free speech
as a meta issue that trumps all other
issues that's another calling card of
the intellectual dark web anyone who has
thought about meta issues in political
and economic society almost always
includes the role of speech at the top
of the list I included along with how
politics are financed the media world
and our economic system those are the
meta issues there is nothing unique or
notable
there let's take a more specific example
one of the sort of common ideas that I'm
seeing on the intellectual dark web is
ideas around taxation right where what
we have is unfair it punishes success
and you end up with some version of a
flat tax or a semi flat tax that's
getting presented now is some kind of
compromise between who knows what
arbitrary positions on either side flat
taxes have been floating around forever
right it's it's not unique it's not new
it's not even remotely interesting and
that is why it is abundantly clear that
the entire intellectual dark web dark
web movement is not an intellectual
movement it's a movement around
marketing and presentation style
combined with using the Internet and
social media period that is all there's
nothing unique period and the solution
sadly is not real intellectuals right if
you think that real intellectuals will
solve the problem of pseudo intellectual
ism that's like thinking if I just
explained the facts about gay marriage
to my homophobic cousin he'll
immediately change his mind we actually
know that the opposite is often true
being presented with information that
seeks to disprove or contradict your
worldview our understanding of the world
will often just further ingrain you in
those beliefs the real problem is the
environment in which the faux
intellectual nonsense of these people is
not only able to take hold but actually
welcomed with open arms as I described
earlier in this discussion and that's
what I don't know how to change the faux
intellectuals the intellectual dark web
and all of that stuff is a consequence
of the problem that we have in society
which I've identified for a long time in
many conversations about both anti
intellectualism
and pseudo intellectual ism so send me
your thoughts about how I've laid this
out
if I'm wrong change my mind
tell me what unique or notable ideas are
actually coming out of the so called
intellectual dark web I'm on twitter at
des Pakman and the show is on twitter at
david pakman show